o sea x igual a esta función que tenemos
aquí y nos preguntan para qué valores de
x la gráfica de g de esta función que
tengo aquí tienen un punto de inflexión
así que primero vamos a recordar que es
un punto de inflexión el punto de
inflexión es donde cambiamos la
concavidad o podemos decir donde la
segunda derivada con respecto a x de la
función original cambia de signo así que
lo voy a poner así cambia
entonces qué te parece si nos fijamos en
nuestra segunda derivada y para trabajar
con la segunda derivada bueno primero
vamos a encontrar quién es la segunda
derivada así que para eso voy a escribir
la función original la voy a escribir
aquí tengo 7 x
es igual
un cuarto a un cuarto de x elevada a la
cuarta potencia menos 4x elevado al cubo
más 24 x cuadrado más 24 x cuadrada muy
bien y ahora vamos a calcular la primera
derivada la primera derivada de esta
función requiere aplicar la regla de la
potencia es decir voy a multiplicar 4
por 144 por un cuarto es 1 así que no lo
voy a escribir y después me va a quedar
x elevado a la 4 menos uno lo cual es 3
muy bien a esto le voy a quitar y ahora
voy a multiplicar esta potencia por 4 me
va a quedar 3 por 4 12
x a la potencia 3 - 1 es decir x
cuadrada y por último voy a agarrar este
lo voy a multiplicar por este 24 y me va
a quedar más 48 48 x muy bien y ahora
vamos a calcular la segunda derivada que
mi prima de x va a ser igual y otra vez
vamos a aplicar la regla de la potencia
me va a quedar este lo voy a multiplicar
por este me quedaría 3x cuadrada y
después a éste lo pueden multiplicar por
12 me va a quedar menos 24 x más 48
48 muy bien así que podemos pensar en
donde esta función de quien cambia de
signo y bueno si observas ésta es una
función continua que está definida para
toda x así que los únicos candidatos
potenciales en donde la segunda derivada
cambia de signo es cuando esta expresión
de aquí es igual a cero entonces vamos a
buscar 3x cuadrada menos 24 x más 48 es
igual a cero así que voy agarrar este
color y voy a buscar donde 3x cuadrada
menos 24 x 48 esto de aquí es igual a 0
y ahora observa que todos divisible
entre 3
entonces si dividimos todo entre 3 me
quedarían x cuadrada menos 8 x
1616 esto igual a 0 y estos factores
hablé si es actualizable esto es lo
mismo que x menos 4 por x menos 4 o x
menos 4 esto elevado al cuadrado y bueno
esto va a ser igual a 0 y de aquí voy a
obtener que x igual a 4 hacen que esta
expresión se cumpla es decir que algo
interesante pasa en x igual a 4 este de
aquí es nuestro candidato vamos a ver si
en efecto la segunda derivada cambia de
signo en este punto o lo así que para
eso deja de hacer por aquí una recta
numérica se me ocurre hacerlo como por
aquí y vamos a ver qué pasa con valores
antes y después de x igual a 4 así que
supongamos que aquí tengo al 2 al 3 por
aquí tengo al 45
muy bien déjame poner con este color que
aquí tengo este valor de x igual a 4 y
bueno nosotros ya sabemos que la segunda
derivada de x cuando x vale 4 esto es
igual a 0
ahora qué te parece si nos tomamos un
valor de x menor que 4 se me ocurre no
sé trabajar con x igualdad 2 nada mejor
con x igual a cero
entonces cuánto vale la segunda derivada
evaluada en cero bueno pues esto me
quedaría esto se va a esto se va y me
queda simple y sencillamente 48 entonces
esto sería igual a 48 lo cual es
positivo eso quiere decir que en todo
este intervalo de aquí en todo este
intervalo aquí la segunda derivada de x
es mayor que 0 o dicho de otra manera en
este intervalo de aquí vamos a tener una
concavidad hacia arriba pero ahora
pensemos qué es lo que pasa a la derecha
de x igual a 4 y para eso qué te parece
si me tomo no sería se me ocurre tomarme
un valor para evaluar mi segunda
derivada pero el valor fácil así que me
voy a fijar en qué es lo que pasa con la
segunda derivada cuando x vale 10 bueno
cuando x vale 10 me va a quedar 10 al
cuadrado 100 x 3
me quedan 300 300 menos 24 por 10 es 240
ok más 48 bueno pues observa que esto es
lo mismo que aquí 300 menos 240 eso es
60 más 48 me va a quedar 108
estos 108 lo cual también es positivo
eso quiere decir que en este intervalo
de aquí en este intervalo de aquí la
segunda derivada de x también va a ser
positiva en ambos lados tendremos una
concavidad hacia arriba en ambos lados
la segunda derivada es positiva y como x
igual a 4 era nuestro único candidato
posible ya que la segunda derivada
evaluada en 4 es igual a 0 entonces no
hay valores para x en donde g tenga un
punto de inflexión si la segunda
derivada cambia de signo al tomarnos un
valor anterior al 4 y 1 posterior ya sea
de positiva negativa o de negativa
positiva entonces este sí sería un punto
de inflexión pero en este ejercicio en
particular se mantiene positiva vamos de
positiva a positiva entonces se vería
más o menos así iría por aquí aquí
tomaría el valor d
y en lugar de cruzar este eje va a
volver a crecer se va a mantener siendo
positiva y bueno si regresamos la
pregunta para qué valores de x la
gráfica gtx tiene un punto de inflexión
ahora sí podemos contestar y la
respuesta va a ser para ninguno
valor de x
valor
x
y voy a poner signos de admiración para
aumentar el dramatismo